they have taken the survey the results
show tons of CCSD students do not feel
safe when in the classroom this less
than a week after an apparent stray
bullet hit a school monitor while they
were working on school grounds thank you
for joining us on 8 news now at five I'm
Brian Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez now
some schools really have some startling
numbers of kids who apparently feel very
unsafe and that can impact their ability
to learn 8 news now education reporter
Joshua peguero joining us in studio to
break down those numbers for us Brian
Denise district-wide one in four
students don't feel safe that number is
heavily influenced by these five schools
either the high schools where kids feel
the less safe at Cheyenne only two in
five students feel safe Legacy basic
Chaparral nearly half their student
population
we also recognize the challenge with the
availability and use of social media
putting isolated incidents on display
that may not represent the overall
student perceptions revealed on the
survey results the survey results were
presented at Thursday's school board
meeting and board president Evelyn
Garcia Morales Says student safety is a
complicated issue safety is not an
isolated
challenge that there are lots of layers
to this and classroom size may be a part
part of the challenge as well that we
have to address students will ask
various questions and the responses
varied by high school but largely an
overwhelming number of kids responded
the schools that felt less safe had
problems with bullying and Cheyenne 51
percent of students say the school did a
good job in preventing bullying Legacy
was at 54 basic 53 and Chaparral 55 the
superintendent Dr Jesus genre blamed
problems in the community there's a lot
of violence in the community that's
building into our campuses so we are
deeply concerned some changes that we're
going to make the changes include
introducing metal detectors in August at
some schools on Thursday we reported the
district wants 21 million dollars to
Dublin's police force adding officers at
elementary and middle schools if we're
going to keep our teachers learning that
teachers teaching and our children
learning this is an investment that the
state needs to make
now for some of these schools the Legacy
in Cheyenne in particular uh yeah Legacy
shine in particular schools where police
issued the most criminal citations so
far this year Brian Joshua thank you for
that now as for the CCSD high schools
where students felt the most safe all
the magnet schools scored high with
veterans tribute career and Tech Academy
at Northwest Career Tech students
reported feeling at those schools the
safest